need motivation watch a top 10 of belief
nation
a lot of people don't read because
they're afraid of books
the books aren't their friend so you
might want to get a few books and kind
of make them your friend
you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction written for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um
different topics or a beginner's guide i
read those things all the time when i'm
first investigating a new topic
you know i start with the introductory
material
um and i make time for reading like
and it was that was encouraged in my
family like i always read before i went
to sleep i read
and i i still do that
um
somewhat less so because i've become so
distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before i went to bed i go to bed turn
the light and read for when i was a kid
for hours but and if you do something
every day you do a lot of it and so i
would say well if you want to read if
you want to make yourself educated just
put aside
20 minutes a day to read or 10
you know some small amount of time that
you could actually steal not two hours
because good luck man
it's very unlikely you'll manage that
but 20 minutes a day
you know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books
and so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value you
investigate carefully what resistances
you might have to that idea because you
might think well that's
uh
pseudo-intellectual or
there's something more productive i
could be doing or i'm intimidated by
books or i hate books because i wasn't
good at reading when i was a kid and was
humiliated because of it or you know
you've got something against
intellectuals or
god there might all sorts of resistances
to picking up a book then you could
listen to audiobooks that's a good way
around that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too it's
like well why should you read
well it's so that you're more informed
and you can think better
why should you be more informed and
think better because you won't walk
blindly into so many pits
you know you'll be able to negotiate
better in your life because you'll be
more informed and more verbally fluent
and you'll have a better sense of how
the world works and be able to hold your
own in conversations and that'll make
you more confident those are all
unbelievably good reasons
to be highly literate is is an
incredibly
massive massive advantage
practical advantage you know and it
shouldn't be underestimated rule number
two consult your irritability i already
knew that i was pretty decent monster by
the time i had kids and i thought well
my kid my kids little you know like a
baby or two-year-olds like i'm a
horrible monster and so that there's an
uneven power problem here i better not
let that child do anything that really
makes me angry you know now you hear now
and then you hear about something
horrible that happens i when i was in
boston years ago i read about a woman
who plunged her two-year-old daughter's
arms into boiling water you think well
how in the world can that happen it's
like well you know
she's probably hungover
she probably just lost her job
she's probably desperate in six
different ways she probably didn't have
any decent discipline at her
disciplinary strategies for children she
probably didn't have anyone helping her
she was bitter and resentful and angry
and the child misbehaved at exactly the
wrong moment and like you're going to be
around your children a lot and so you
might want to have it so that they don't
misbehave at exactly the wrong moment
because all hell can break loose if they
can and i didn't want that to happen so
and i knew that it was easy for people
to hate their children even though they
mouth the words that they love them all
the time i saw very little evidence of
that many situations and so
one of the things you know you have a
natural affinity for children and even
more maybe a more powerful natural
affinity for your own children so that's
a good start but you don't want to set
them up as an enemy against you you
don't want to allow them to engage in
the kind of hierarchical challenge that
makes you irritable and resentful that's
not a good idea and if the things they
do make you dislike them the probability
that they will make other people dislike
them is extraordinarily high and so you
can consult your own irritability and
you can say look kid i used to tell my
kids this you know when they were three
or four i'd say look i'm not in a very
good mood and i'm likely to be
unreasonable so it'd be best if you'd go
in your room and play for a while it's
like i like you man you're a great kid
but like get the hell out of here for a
while you know and they were fine with
that we'd train them already at that
point to be able to go play by
themselves in the room you know which is
something a kid should be able to do
anyways but
but you need to know what sort of
monster you are if you're going to be a
good parent and if you think oh i'm not
a monster it's like oh yes you are
you're just an unbelievably unconscious
monster and that's actually the worst
kind
so and then the other thing about that
chapter is there's an idea in it and and
it's an idea that i think is well
supported by the relevant literature
which is that your fundamental job as a
parent especially of a child from zero
to four is to make that child eminently
desirable socially
so what you're you're a successful
parent if when your child is four
all sorts of other children want to play
with him or her that's really the that's
like if you want one marker of whether
or not you've been successful that's it
now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so i'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that i'm not saying
that i'm saying the reverse which is you
can be sure that you've been successful
if your child is not popular exactly but
desirable as a playmate and so then you
think well what have you done for your
child well you've opened up the entire
world of children to them so because
they know how to play which is a very
deep knowledge and it starts to become
inculcated probably at the breast and
certainly in the course of rough and
tumble play at about two years of age
it's a deep embodied knowledge they know
how to play like a good well-trained dog
knows how to play you know you meet a
new dog and you go like this and the dog
goes like this you think oh that dog it
i can go like this and it won't bite me
right it knows how to play and a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that
like a well-socialized kid if you know
anything about kids is you can take a
four-year-old make a little play gesture
at them and they'll smile right away and
start playing just right now and that's
what you want for your kids and then
everywhere they go other kids like them
and will include them in their play and
play is the way the children develop and
so if other children include them in
their play then the children develop and
the poor kids that don't get befriended
at the age of four with the literature
on this is crystal clear if your child
is an outcast at the age of four the
probability that anything can be done
about that is almost zero no matter what
you do
and i hate to be so blunt about that but
i know the literature and that's what
the literature suggests rule number
three tame the dragon there's a part of
the brain called the hypothalamus and
it's very very very old we share it with
virtually every animal that has a
nervous system it's
it's
sits above the spinal cord it's
extremely old evolutionarily speaking
and half of it governs fundamental
motivations so
governs hunger for example so if you're
hungry
you posit the existence of something
that will satiate your appetite a peanut
butter sandwich and then you're happy
when you're moving towards the kitchen
and then maybe you get thirsty and the
hypothalamus does that and then maybe
you need to use the washroom and maybe
you're too hot and that the hypothalamus
pops up these little motivational frames
and then emotions modulate your movement
towards the goal that's established by
these fundamental motivations but that's
only half the hypothalamus the other
half is the origin of the dopaminergic
system that
mediates exploratory striving and
positive emotion and so the way our
brains are set up way below what
way below the neocortex way way older
than that
the default position is if you're
satiated in all the important dimensions
then you're curious and explore
well why well because you might find new
resources that could be used to
to to uh uh satiate those fundamental
motivations in the future so that heroic
drive into the unknown is unbelievably
archaic
and then it's regulated by fear and pain
you know so you go into the unknown well
you don't want to die so if you get
damaged you experience pain and you want
to avoid pain so you experience anxiety
these are very fundamental systems and
they are reflected in our narratives
that's essentially as far as i can tell
why the dragon
hoards treasure everywhere the dragon is
an amalgam of predatory stimuli
and fire
which is a destructive force but also
very useful so
dragon is something like predatory
destructive entity and you might say
well is that real it's like well yeah
but it's a meta category it's like
there are lions and raptors and
um
lizards
let's say uh 60 million years ago when
we were still in trees
the idea that there's a meta predator is
a great idea
a meta predator is what all predators
share in common
that's a dragon well what should you do
with a dragon
well avoid it that's one answer another
answer is burn it out of its lair so
that it doesn't have baby dragons
the and the
an even more sophisticated answer is
well
confront it
you can feed your family with the body
of a dragon
it's treasure rule number four be of
service there's a higher order moral
principle that needs to be brought into
the situation and you sort of described
that right at the beginning of the
question because you said well
what partly what you do when you move
from an addicted state from a
psychological perspective is move from a
viewpoint of the gratification of
immediate desire and and maybe the
accumulation of things as a marker of
success to the notion that no you
actually have a higher purpose and that
higher purpose might involve being of
service that could be of service to
yourself which means you wouldn't be
addicted anymore because that's not a
good way of being of service to yourself
but of service to yourself and the
broader community however you might
define that that's a higher order
purpose and it can integrate your
motivations at at a level that doesn't
leave you at the whim of impulse that's
the purpose of a higher order motivation
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five make things
better you do what you can to make the
things around you better you better your
family better and then whatever you can
manage in your community
you know um
if you're interested in the drug
addicted and the mentally ill you know
there are volunteer you could volunteer
you could talk to those people and
listen
because then you'd find out what the
hell their problems are and then you'd
have some sense about how they might be
helped you know but that's a hard thing
there's no
helping from above
drug addiction and it's combination of
mental illness unbelievably complicated
problems there's no simple solutions
so and it isn't even necessarily obvious
that the people that you see who are
homeless and drug addicted mentally ill
don't want to be helped is that
sometimes they have problems that are so
absolutely overwhelming that they can't
be helped
in any real sense you know like if
they're
unmedicated schizophrenic for example
with a drug problem it's god it's just
it's just a nightmarish
it's a nightmare of insane complexity
because schizophrenia is very very
difficult to deal with even
even
with medication because the
medication that helps people who are
schizophrenic also tends to depress
their positive emotion and decrease
their motivation
you know so the medications are
generally helpful and the proper
treatment guidelines if you're
schizophrenic generally are
stay with your medication
because
despite the negative consequences of the
medication which aren't trivial
the consequences of not taking it are
worse and that's a real hobson's choice
right it's a bit of hell in both
directions
but if you really want to know
i would say
go have some
contact with those people
and listen to them
and learn what the problems are maybe
you could start seeing what might be
helpful it's a really complicated
problem
and it's different than the problem of
helping people who don't want to be
helped because
you have to figure out who it is that
doesn't want to be helped first and you
don't want to assume that just because
someone's homeless that they don't want
to be helped
i mean
that doesn't mean that it's easy to
figure out how to help them
it's not easy it's helping people is a
very difficult business and it's a very
dangerous business too because you get
tangled up in ways that you wouldn't
expect and that can be
an occupational hazard let's put it that
way rule number six maintain
attractiveness if you don't allow your
children to engage in dislikable
behavior then adults will like them
because adults actually like kids you
know one of the things i loved about
having little kids in montreal i lived
in a poor area in montreal there's a lot
of rough guys around there and we used
to roll our daughter around in the
stroller and these rough guys you know
like
god only knows what they were up to
they're rough looking guys you know we'd
roll our daughter by them and they'd
they'd like smile and they'd crouch down
and make little goo faces and you know
they were you i tell you one of the
great things about having little kids is
they bring out the best in other people
you see a whole side of humanity even
among the darker parts of humanity you
see a whole side of them that you
wouldn't normally see and it's lovely
and the thing is if you're good to your
kid in the real way you can help them
maintain that tremendous attractiveness
that they have as young children and to
respond to adults properly like a puppy
that wags its tail instead of growls and
you know goes for your ankle and then
wherever they go adults welcome them and
teach them things and pat them on the
head and smile at them genuinely instead
of saying oh my god here comes that
couple with that goddamn brat again
you know which is the horrible that's
horrible thing to do to a child because
then everywhere they go all the good all
the good will is false
you know there's nothing that you can do
to someone that's more terrible than to
put them in a world where all the good
will directed towards them is false
that's a terrible thing rule number
seven put your act together i took what
i learned about what happened in the
second world war seriously
it's like wow
we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
well was it or not well how unacceptable
was it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
we'll make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
there's something jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that
each individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something
upon which the world increasingly
depends
for its maintenance rule number eight
overcome rumination how do i stop
ruminating these thoughts are recurring
and relate to every and any embarrassing
moment i have ever had during my
lifetime
i'm a 76 year old woman well oh well
here's something you could try
write down everything that you're
ruminating about
i know that seems counterproductive but
like see ruminations come up
accidentally involuntarily unconsciously
whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about you're
facing them voluntarily so i would say
well
open up a journal or word document
whatever and write down every time you
ruminate about something
write it down and write down every
rumination you can remember exhaustively
write them all down
that would be the first thing and the
second thing is standard behavioral
therapy practice the second thing the
next thing would be
um
write down why you think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you might
have done about them then
but more importantly what you could do
about them in the future to avoid that
because it doesn't matter that something
embarrassing happened to you once what
matters is
whether or not you're likely to repeat
it in the future but my suspicions are
that even if you just
you could just start simply
write down every ruminating ruminating
thought that you have
voluntarily
and and think about them in detail and
write them down in detail get every
little word down
and
then you have that document and then
when you have a thought and start to
ruminate on it
then
sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily
so every time you have a thought you
don't want to have
later practice having that thought on
purpose
and try that for about a month
and see what happens because it's often
the case that if you start thinking
about
the thoughts you're ruminating on
consciously and confront them
voluntarily that they will start to go
away rule number nine don't dwell on
revenge you see these mass shootings all
the time and everyone does the same
thing oh how did that happen why did
that happen how can it be this way it's
like
well why don't you read what they said
about why they did it just assume that
that's the reason and if you go if you
go
oh well the columbine kids
oh yeah it was like oh they must have
been bullied oh yes because you know the
natural response of anyone who's been
bullied is to go arm yourself to the
teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city i think it was of detroit to
line your entire high school avenue with
bombs and then to go and shoot your
classmates that's what happens when
you're bullied it's like no that that's
not what happens when you're bullied
that's a stupid explanation it's shallow
beyond belief and it and it really
emerges only because people don't want
to contend with the real issue and the
columbine kids well they were contending
with the real issue you know they
basically said quite forthrightly that
in their own arrogant estimation being
itself was corrupt and unnecessary and
it would be best if it was eradicated in
the most brutal possible way as fast as
possible
and you get to places like that if you
dwell on revenge for three or four years
in your mom's basement you know you can
go to very dark places and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is aim at something pick
something
pick something aim at it as you move
toward it you'll get wiser then maybe
your aim will change that's okay but at
least it'll change in an informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and i think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that
i shouldn't say that because i don't
believe that i think you can find
yourself in a situation that's so dire
that you don't there's no escape from it
but
that doesn't matter because
this still this is the hero myth might
not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have
i mean everyone dies and so we fail in
some sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to
the lecture is a form of theater now
it's a serious form of theater but
theater can be serious you know and and
there's a see because partly what i'm
doing is i'm presenting ideas to an
audience but i'm also modeling the act
of engaging with ideas and that's the
theatrical
end of it and i don't give the same talk
twice like i have my stories and i have
my collection of things i know and i
talk about but
i try to i try to do two things um i try
to in i'm always talking to specific
individuals in the audience and so i'm
having a conversation with the audience
and so that's that's part of the dynamic
element of the performance and the other
thing i'm trying to do is to further my
thinking on the topics that i'm
addressing and there is a theatrical
element to that because it's it's like i
think this the closest thing really that
it compares to is probably stand-up
comedy although i think
the routines that comedians have are
probably more
well and formally practiced than the
ones that that you know than than the
than the talks that i that i engage in i
don't really think of it as delivering a
lecture to an audience i'm trying to
think about complicated things
in real time
with an audience there to participate
and and to use the audience as
an indicator of whether what i'm saying
is gripping and comprehensible you know
silicon valley tends to be liberal every
everyone knows that and the reason for
that is that there's a tremendous number
of entrepreneurs there and entrepreneurs
tend to be high in openness and lower in
conscientiousness so they're creative
but they're also willing to break rules
you know which you kind of have to do
often
hopefully not to a criminal extent but
you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because look at a company like uber you
know they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just kind of went ahead and did it it's
not something an orderly person would do
because they'd ask for permission
whereas the people who started these
scooter rental companies just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but you know
you have to have a rule-breaking
proclivity in order to manage that take
a bit of a look at yourself and think
about what's not so good that you could
improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this stack
of paper there you know and you haven't
looked at that damn stack for like a
month and you know that you should be
and you're
bothering yourself at night because
you're avoiding that it's like maybe
think i've avoided that stack of paper
completely for one month i'm quite a
coward when it comes to whatever snakes
might be hidden in that stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like
i glance through it for
15 seconds
see if i can do that
it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper
you know it could easily be you've been
avoiding it you're obviously afraid of
it and so the situation could be that
dismal and dire
and you might think well geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the
strength of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of and so that's a form
of humility too it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction and then the
question is are you big enough to take
those small steps you know are you
capable of grappling with the fact that
you're fundamentally flawed to the point
where you have to break things down into
almost child-like steps in order to
manage them and the answer to that is
yeah you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out generally
you get better at it and you can take on
larger and larger challenges in any case
people do waste a lot of time and they
are they also act counterproductively a
lot of the time
regardless we do make progress and and
and and we can
thrive
under the difficult conditions that make
up our lives and we can resist the
malevolence that entices us that's
within our power
and we don't know the limits to that and
we also know that
it's better
to
we all know this
that it's better
to live
courageously
than cowardly
everyone knows that that's what you
teach people that you love
and
and
and we know that it's better to live
truthfully than in deceit
and you can tell that too because that's
also what you tell people that you love
and we know that
you should
pick up your damn responsibility
and move forward everyone knows that
it's it's part of our intrinsic
moral
nature
and that nature is there and
it's not difficult to communicate to
people about this like
everyone knows that you wake up at three
in the morning when you've left let your
life go off the rails and that you
berate yourself for your
uselessness and your cruelty and your
failure to take off
to take the opportunities that are in
front of you and if you were the master
in your own house in some sense
the captain of your own destiny if there
was no intrinsic nature well that would
never happen you'd just let yourself off
the hook there'd be no voice of
conscience tormenting you
but no one escapes from that and what
that indicates to me is that at least
psychologically
we live in a universe that's
characterized by a moral dimension and
we understand that well and that moral
failings have consequences and that
they're not trivial they destroy you
they destroy your family they destroy
your community and and you can tell
people that
and they listen because they know
they don't know they know
that's the thing and maybe that's the
thing about being an
intellectual you have the opportunity to
articulate
ideas that other people know they embody
but they can't articulate and that's
what people tell me you know they say
well
you help me
give words to things that i always knew
to be true but couldn't say
or
or they say i've been trying to put some
of your precepts into practice
responsibility being a main one vision
another honesty i i suppose bringing up
the pack and saying this is the fun part
of doing all this
fun is a weak word that it's it's it's a
it's the remarkable part of doing all
this i mean i have people tell me
constantly wherever i go
it's so delightful that
you know they're in a pretty dark place
and they tell me why and there's plenty
of dark places in the world and they
decided well
maybe they were going to develop a bit
of a vision and take a bit more
responsibility if you really want to
solve a complicated problem maybe you
try to solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs this is
something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail
at
producing their creative product and
monetizing it right so your default
position if you're a creative person is
you're going to fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's j
and it's hard to
present it to the market at the right
time and it's hard to market it like
those things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and eventually if they're fortunate
one of their ideas happens to hit
the right place at the right time and so
that's also
darwinian in some sense you know you're
creating all these little enterprises
that are sort of alive
they're they're run by people after all
and even if your idea is good that
doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so this is partly why
persistence and that's part of
conscientiousness is so useful it's like
you know what are they safe if at first
you fail then try try again and um and
that would probably mean try something
different rather than the same thing
but
persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and and you need to know that the
baseline is failure
you know it's important because
otherwise you'll blame that on yourself
i would say for the last 45 years we've
told
psychologists have been
have been certainly to blame for this at
least in part
you're okay the way you are that's what
we tell young people oh you're okay the
way you are it's like
and there's nothing worse than you can
tell that you can tell someone who's
young than that
especially if they're miserable
you know and lots of them well if
they're miserable and aimless it's like
oh i'm miserable and aimless and
sometimes i'm suicidal and i'm
nihilistic and i don't have any
direction in your life it's in my life
it's like well you're okay the way you
are here and it's like they don't want
to hear that they want to hear look you
know
you're
and you know this you're
useless
you know nothing you haven't got started
you've got 60 years to put yourself
together and god only knows what you
could become
and that's so
that message is so much more it's so
funny because it's so
it's such an attack
but it's so positive
because there's faith there in the in
the potential that makes up the person
rather than the miserable actuality that
happens to be manifesting itself at the
moment and young people respond
extraordinarily well to that because
when you know that if you're a parent
and you love your
your child your son your daughter
what you're trying to foster
is the best in them you want that to
manifest itself across the course of
their life you want them to become
continually more than they are to see
what they could be
and
well and i think that's part of the
great message of the west is that that's
that's the that's the ethical
requirement of individual
being in in in the proper sense is to
constantly
note that you're not what you could be
to take responsibility for that and to
and to
commit yourself like body and soul to
the attainment of that ideal the first
thing i think you need to understand is
that these people that you're comparing
yourself to you don't really know
very well
you know and
um
what that means is that you see they're
shiny outside but you don't see the
reality of their life
and so what you're
[Applause]
you know maybe you're in california see
someone speeding down the road in a in a
convertible portion you think oh man
what a lucky bastard and um
the truth of the matter is that he's
thinking about wrapping his expensive
sports car around the next cement pillar
that he comes close to
you know you can't tell and people have
hard lives and and even people who are
comparatively fortunate have hard lives
and
so
the the ideal
that you're observing that makes you
jealous and resentful is in large part
an illusion that's created by your own
mind
and i
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i i can give you just one
example is like i know a fair number of
extremely wealthy people and
um most of them most of the people i
happen to know are people who've made
them their money themselves and i tell
you man they have a burden of
responsibility that would crush
me
would would crush the typical person
they're just working
flat out
like 90 hours a week and they have
thousands of people depending on them
and you know they have their money and
and they have their status and that's
not nothing but
don't be thinking that there isn't a
price to be paid for that you know they
don't see their families they're often
divorced they don't see their children
grow up and
and they don't have time off now there
are
wealthy
what would you call playboy types i
suppose who
live out the
dreams of wealth of a foolish 14 year
old but
they're not that common and
you have to be careful of what you're
jealous of because you don't really know
what it is
and then the other thing that's kind of
useful is to
well to understand that you're different
from everyone else and
this is especially true as you get older
when when you're 17 or 16 or something
like that comparing yourself to other
people makes a certain amount of sense
because 16 and 17 year olds they're kind
of the same you know which is why
when you go off to university you can
make friends so quickly it's like
i'm i'm just about 60. it takes me like
15 years to make a friend now you know
as opposed to the two months that it
took when i was 17. 17
you're you're quite different from other
people and you shouldn't be comparing
yourself to them because they're not
like you
you know
they don't have your family they don't
have your temperament they don't have
your troubles they don't have your
abilities
the only person that
[Applause]
[Applause]
the only the only person that has those
is you
and this is why
one of the rules i think it's rule four
is compare yourself to who you were
yesterday and not to who someone else is
today
and see that's a game you can win
because
you could be a little better today than
you were yesterday
and that's a good thing
you're a little better that that's a
good thing and and you know no doubt
there are some things that you could
improve you know if you if you sit and
meditate for any length of time about
what you're not doing optimally
answers will spring to mind you have to
be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well
and it might be so embarrassing that you
can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
fathom that that's actually who you are
but you know
jung described the full
the archetypal figure of the trickster
and the fool as the precursor to the
savior to the redeemer and that's
unbelievable bit of wisdom because
what you meant was that
to put yourself together which is to
follow the path of redemption
to follow the redeemer
if the redeemer is a type of personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
or manifest
then this first step towards that is to
allow yourself to be a fool
right
it's because
you you don't know what you're doing
you have to admit that and there's going
to be a loss of ego or destruction of
ego arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that but you need the loss
of that arrogant ego because it's
precisely what's interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process mythologically
speaking that stops moral progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice what you're like so that
you could change properly you don't want
to sacrifice that part of yourself it's
probably associated with some delusion
that helps you maintain
in uh
what you say a positive although very
fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort you can look
at that pessimism that that
constitutes let's say the core of what
well i think it's the core religious
message really is the is the tragic
nature of the world the reality of
suffering it's it's part of the core
religious message but what emerges out
of that
properly conceptualized is
a remarkable appreciation for what human
beings are capable of like we are
unbelievably
resilient and
and able creatures and we do not have
any conception of our upper limits
you'll discover a little bit more about
your potential as you discover who you
are especially the darker parts of
yourself
because then you discover your potential
for mayhem there's some real utility in
that you know a discovery that you're
dangerous it's such a useful discovery
it's actually something that strengthens
you because
the first
thing that a realization like that can
in fact produce is
the
the ambition to incorporate that danger
into a higher order personality that
dangerousness into a higher order
personality and that can make you
implacable
i can make you someone who can say no
when you need to say no
you know that can make you someone who
won't avoid necessary conflict and so
that's
as unbelievably useful when you're
moving through life and you have a plan
or a dream and it shatters you know
someone dies or a relationship breaks
apart or you you have a terrible upset
in your career or you become ill in some
unexpected way then everything around
you falls apart and you plunge into a
well you plunge into a chaotic
underworld the belly of the wild that's
exactly right yes exactly that and then
maybe you stay there because it isn't
necessarily the case that people get out
you know people die people are in
despair permanently but
frequently
something tragic and terrible befalls
you and you fall apart
and you learn something profound as a
consequence and you put yourself back
together and when you come back out
you're more than you were when you went
in and that's happening in at a small
scale every time you learn something you
know you if you ever really learn
something it's usually painful it
usually means that you have to recognize
that you're wrong in some important way
you have to let that part of you that's
wrong die and then you have to let a new
part of you okay so the self imagine
that
you undergo a series of transformations
in your life there are
there are collapses into the chaotic
underworld and then
many resurrections that happens
continually tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail
you say here's something worth going
after here's a step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are but
that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone
you're expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay i need to set a
goal but i need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it right and then you got
then you've got it perfectly because
it's not so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well i could do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you wanted to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
swallowing being a victim yeah which
isn't helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem you have to move
from point a to b in life but point a is
often a very difficult place to be
because we're fragile and bounded and
mortal and limited and because we know
that and so one of the
implications of that as many great
religious traditions are at pains to
illustrate or demonstrate or proclaim
is that life is essentially suffering
and i believe that to be a fundamental
truth but
but perhaps not the most fundamental
truth because i think the most
fundamental truth is that despite the
fact that life is suffering people can
transcend that and partly the way they
transcend that is by pursuing things of
value and so that if there is no value
proposition at hand then you have no
meaning to justify the difficult
conditions of your life and that's
brutally difficult for people you know
nietzsche said
he who has a
why can bear any how
and you see and i've certainly seen this
as a clinical practitioner that people
who have no purpose in their life
are embittered by the difficulties of
their life and they become first bitter
and then resentful and then revengeful
and then cruel and there's plenty of
places to go past cruel that's just
where you start if you're really on a
downhill path we didn't understand
that truth comes in different forms
depending on its application it's a
tricky thing there's the truths that
apply when you're attempting to describe
the transformations of the material
world and there's the truths that apply
when you're trying to determine how it
is that you should act while you're
alive and those obviously those have to
come into alignment but they're not in
alignment right now and my sense and
this is a sense that's been
developed at least in part from reading
the great psychoanalysts is that
fictional accounts meta-fictional
accounts even like biblical accounts
which are mythological are stories about
how it is that people should act not
stories about what the material
structure of the world is the more
radical the necessary change the more
pain that accompanies it
like the more opportunity as well but
and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out
and so the fact that people flee from
that is hardly surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better
the better
idea is to eat a little poison every day
so that you don't have to overdose in a
month it's something like that
and it is the case that i think because
you don't you aren't forced to first of
all you don't learn unless you're forced
to learn i know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that
speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out
it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning
and there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility is to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can but you have to have a very
tragic
i would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you
and
that makes you desperate enough to learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though one of
the things i've been talking to my
audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons
but you need something to put
up against that
and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better
yeah that's better guilting yourself
you're not feeling bad about yourself
that's right you feel that you've
justified you've justified your
existence right and so you're not waking
up at three in the morning in a cold
sweat thinking about all the terrible
things that you've involved yourself in
what you said to someone that you
shouldn't have said or how you acted or
what opportunity you lost or or or yeah
or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that
and so
if you think about the times when you're
at peace with yourself with regards to
how you're conducting yourself in the
world it's almost always conditions
under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt i think that you can
experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that we kind
of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if i can if i can put this
properly
that you have a certain delightful
wonderful positive freedom as a child
and then that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic way more people than you
think and part of that is because no
one's ever really encouraged them and so
the book is in part a matter of
encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in in check and then you can move
towards a state that's freer because
it's disciplined first like look if
you're going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
freedom your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the if you being eaten wasn't a
real possibility
it wouldn't be a real fight
and so you see people like i've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
i had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything
at her disposal to do so and i
strategized with him for about three
years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much he got backed into a corner
so hard that i didn't know how to help
him anymore
so
i would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did
manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say he did manage to
establish what i think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got
enough out of what he did to justify it
even though
the whole landscape was pretty
awful
i think that
not lying is your best bet
but
life is hard and people get run over and
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to emerge in any obvious sense
triumphant
but
if you take the alternative path path
especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it people came
to my website because they were
interested in well before the political
stuff blew up i had a million views on
youtube which is nothing a million of
anything is a lot
but then when the political scandal
started to break yeah then people came
for them but stayed for the content and
so and that's been very useful yeah well
it's well and it's not that surprising
well you know because of what you do
it's like
there's a great hunger for information
that is
practical and useful and
that helps people
find meaning in their lives and orient
themselves there's a great hunger for
that and most of my lectures were
derived from
solid psychology some of it experimental
some of it biological some of it from
from from the domains of neuroscience a
lot of it from great clinicians it's not
surprising that people find it helpful
because well great clinicians were great
because they were really helpful and so
to distill that and to offer it to
people in a digestible form to have that
have a good effect on them well that's
that's what you'd expect that's what the
whole discipline is about and so that's
been that's been great this
circumambulation that jung talked about
was this
continual
will return to this this continual
circling in some sense of who you could
be you might notice for example that
there are themes in your life you know
when you go back across your experiences
you see you kind of have your typical
experience that sort of repeats itself
and there might be variation on it like
a musical theme but it's it's like
you're circling yourself and getting
closer to yourself as you move across
time that's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second we'll go back
to it okay so imagine that something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning and you decide well first
of all you're paralyzed you think well
how do i know if i should pursue that
it's probably a stupid idea and the
proper response to that is you're right
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all ideas are stupid and so the
the probability that as you move forward
on your adventure that you're going to
get it right the first time is zero it's
just not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe i'll just wait
around until i get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's
nietzsche called that a will to
stupidity which i really liked
so because he thought of stupidity as
being it
you know it's it's you have to take it
into account fundamentally and work with
it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps
on your
pathway to destiny and you can assume
that you're going to do it badly and
that's really useful because you don't
have to beat yourself up it's pretty
easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all you
start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and
then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were
it's it's going to reveal itself with
more accuracy to you and so then you
have to take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
i mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than
you would be if you just stayed where
you were waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress the
degree of overshooting starts to decline
the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean you have to stop
and thank god for that that's a really
useful thing
and the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean that you can't learn and so
you can posit an ideal and you're going
to be wrong about it but it doesn't
matter because what you're right about
is positing the ideal moving towards it
if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you going to do that's perfect so
it doesn't matter that it's imperf
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as i'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that so that's
that's useful you're one of the best
communicators that i've ever listened to
if i could be
half as good
at you or at communicating as you are i
would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things is
it helps to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think and if you can
do that a little bit every day
15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're gonna speak effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side
well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals and you
talk to them so when i talk to a group i
always talk to people one at a time and
that makes it easier too because you
know how to talk to a person it's like
can you talk to a thousand people well
probably not because it's too
intimidating but there isn't a thousand
people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell
if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they give you feedback about how
you're doing and so one thing is to to
have something to say
yeah but the next thing is pay attention
to who you're talking to
because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know
and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but in first but on first sight
you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about it you're actually
engaged in a conversation with an
audience even if they're not
talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or
and you can you can pull all that in and
and and use it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well i
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate i don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter i mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so
the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges i think
i don't know if they've forgotten it but
they don't do a very good job of
marketing it's like what's the use of a
bachelor's degree a bachelor of arts
it's like well
you can think
you can write
you can speak
you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that i've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're sick it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice there is definitely an epidemic
of overprotective parenting
but it's useful to ask why
and my suspicions are is that this is
driven by very fundamental
biological and cultural phenomena that
aren't generally considered in
relationship to this issue
we don't have very many children
we don't have
12
you know six of whom die
we have one
or two and that makes them very precious
right we're unwilling to take risks with
them and no wonder
and then we also have them much later in
life
and so like if you have a kid when
you're 18 you're still a kid you know
you're gonna go out and have your life
right because you're so
well you're in the in the height of your
exploratory
you're in the height of the exploratory
part of your life
you're not going to over protect your
kid because you're still a kid
but if you're 40 and you have one child
it's like
all your eggs are in one basket and the
probability that you're going to take
undue risks with that precious person is
very very low now obviously there's some
advantages to that because great you
devote resources to your child you know
and foster their development but
the downside is that you have every
motivation to hover
and maybe you're also extraordinarily
desperate as a mother to
maintain that bond with your child
because you've struggled so long to
achieve it it's highly highly valuable
you can't take a risk
well so
these
so we might say well perhaps
overprotective parenting is a secondary
and unintended consequence of the birth
control pill and the fact that people
now have children later in life could
easily be you know if you have six kids
like what are you gonna do helicopter
parent them it's like no
you're so tired you can't even get off
the couch if you have six kids and
they're they outnumber you right they're
raising each other they're competing and
they're taking each other down a peg
they're not there's no overprotection
there
but with it with a single child
landscape or dual child landscape
mostly a single child landscape then
you're going to over protect
and then that ethos starts to permeate
the schools and it starts to permeate
the higher education institutions as
those children mature
and then that all reinforces it it's not
good it's not obvious what to do about
it either because if it is driven by
demographics in that in that sense it's
a much more intractable problem than we
think
so i did some of that in 12 rules for
life you know i said look what you have
to understand is that you're a danger to
your children no matter what
right
you can let them go out in the world and
be hurt
or you can over protect them and hurt
them that way so here's your choice can
make your children competent and
courageous or you can make them safe
but you can't make them safe because
life isn't safe
so if you sacrifice their courage and
competence on the altar of safety then
you disarm them completely and all they
can do is pray to be protected you're
going to use what you think to guide
your action and the consequence of that
is going to be how your life turns out
so i'm dead serious about what i write
because because i know what the pathway
is it's like you don't you don't
communicate in a false manner because if
you do you will warp the structure that
guides your actions and you will
absolutely absolutely 100 percent suffer
for that i mean one of the things i've
learned as a clinical psychologist is
that i've never seen anyone it's really
a terrifying thing i've never seen
anyone get away with anything ever
it the chickens always come home to
roost so and sometimes it might you know
let's say you get away with something
it's like yeah you think so man
you wait five years from now seven years
from now it'll come back is that karma
it's more like yes i think it's the same
idea but it's more like
you you can't
you you don't have the power to
manipulate reality
like you have the power to bring about
reality in some sense because you
confront potential and through your
actions and and and your communicative
intent you turn potential into reality
but you don't have the you don't have
the power to bend reality without it
snapping you don't think so
you don't think so so you don't think
visionaries and influencers have the
ability to bend reality no i don't think
they bend it i think that they
they they i mean you can bring new
things into being
but you can't you can't get away with a
falsehood
no you can definitely bring new things
into being you can't get away with a
falsehood yes that's it
okay makes sense and and you can't get
away with weak thinking either
because
i mean any more than you can get away
with improper action it just doesn't
work
so you're you're contending it's what's
why i mean one of the themes in my
writing is the danger of falsehood
and at any at every level it's like well
if you tell the truth to the degree that
you can or at least don't lie that think
that's rule eight
then you have reality on your side
you've got to decide man you want
reality on your side or do you want
reality against you
i wouldn't recommend the whole reality
against you thing because you're not
going to win you're going to get
flattened
and so i'm very careful with what i say
and i'm very careful with what i write
we are thrown
challenges and that they're
that and that in some sense those are
best construed as tests of our ethical
ability so what jung thought his idea
was something like this that
at the beginning of time people were
unconscious
and that consciousness emerged with all
of its catastrophes consciousness of
death for example and
one way out of the burden of
consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness you can do that with
alcohol you can do that by being
dependent you can do that by failing to
grow up you refuse the burden of
consciousness by
becoming unconscious again but there's
another way forward which is to become
even more conscious so the idea would be
a little bit of consciousness is like an
illness but if you can expand that
consciousness upwards enough then it's
time something it starts to become
something that it's all that is its own
cure you know because it's one thing to
live properly and that's not a trivial
thing but it's another thing to be able
to articulate yourself and to be able to
negotiate and generally speaking there's
nothing about that that isn't
advantageous and even introverted and
anxious people can learn to do that you
know it's those are learnable skills
it's not easy but but
but you can manage it
you can also
you can also speak carefully you know
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true that's also unbelievably useful
you have to feel that out like is this
really what i believe or am i putting it
forward well because i want to look good
or i want to dominate or
or i want to express
obliquely an emotion that i'm too
cowardly to come out and confront
directly or am i being manipulative
there's lots of reasons that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is to state what you believe to
be true and then to let the consequences
of that unfold
and so that can also
help you
simple truths
bluntly stated can be very powerful you
don't need a lot of verbal fluency under
those circumstances if there's evidence
of strength of character behind it it's
good for you to go take your place in
the world have some ambition
have some have a vision have a goal have
a strategy try to try to be a good
person in not not because it's your duty
precisely because that's the proper way
to live we're in danger of undermining
all of that and it's not good for people
one of the things that i've really
learned for example recently is that
there's a or learned to articulate
better is that there's a very tight
relationship between aspiration and
responsibility so let's say
well the first question might be do you
need to aspire to something and the
answer is well yes because you have to
do something okay if you just sit there
you'll die you can't just sit there you
have to go act out in the world okay so
act towards what well that's whatever
your aspiration is you have to have an
aim okay well what should the aim be
well it should be something worth doing
let's say what why do something that you
don't feel is worth doing what do you
think's worth doing well if you watch
other people and you judge when they're
doing something worthwhile usually judge
them positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves but you want to be completely
useless so other people have to take
care of you that's pretty pathetic and
maybe you could get your act together so
you're taking care of yourself and your
family and maybe you could even do
better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community there's lots of ways of
defying the crowd let's say i mean
you could live your life the way that
you want to live it that's a matter of
action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is a
inspirational example
so that's not nothing
um
that's that's something live properly in
your defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing
when you when you're debating
because you're taking the manner in
which you act like if you're an
integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
i like i don't know this for sure dave
you know but but generally it's useful
how do you do that um
doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need a value
hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top i would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that
each person is of divine value and that
the most appropriate way of interacting
with potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be
at the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and so
the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it does that in a
manner that's evil and contaminated by
malevolence and hatred and vengefulness
then it takes a pathway that corrupts
the world and makes things worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character your life doesn't have meaning
without aspiration or name okay so you
need a hierarchy of values there's got
to be something at the top it's got to
be something important if you don't have
that your life doesn't have any meaning
so if you criticize the hierarchy or
even the ideas of idea of hierarchy you
destroy the idea of aspiration and then
people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily see if you can put
yourself together see what you can do
out in the world while you're waiting to
die it's an all-in game it better be
worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility and aspiration
and hierarchy and when you criticize
those things you get rid of the
aspiration if you want more top 10
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it go check it out the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
i'll see you there